and I think from a personal point of
view it's not something I've really
heard about until I got involved with
always with this campaign and wanted to
get involved because I know how much of
effect the extracurricular activities
had on my career and the fact that from
their moments gone after school and play
football was what I really got the love
for the sport and decided to have it as
my career so if it hadn't been for the
after-school activities do you think you
wouldn't have ended up following the
career that you have so successfully in
football no definitely not I think for
me it was always having that opportunity
to be able to go and play football after
school because there wasn't that much
time during the day and if it was the
dark nights as well you wanted to just
stay at school you wanted to be with
young you made it you wanted to have fun
and for me being able to take part and
that was something where it was all
different kind of sports but when it
came to football it was like right okay
this is the one and this is where I grew
my confidence and they'll personally I'm
today it really shaped Who I am and as
well as obviously learning to be
brilliant at football what else did you
get out of these clubs what else have we
been missing out on and girls I think
for me I think confidence is a big thing
I think being a part of something that
you really enjoy in yourself you feel a
lot more you feel a lot more better
about yourself I think with your friends
if they see that you're enjoying it they
can help build your confidence that
we're in I think for me personally I
think knowing that I was a little bit
good at something allowed me to grow my
confidence because a lot more people
then try to rely on me I was quite shy
at school and secondary school and even
though I was probably around a popular
group of friends I think I was one of
the ones that took kind of a back seat
and I think from that point on when they
thought I was good at football or or
different sports it was then I started
to build confidence because then you're
always good at something so for me it's
just a real shame that girls missing out
on these opportunities to do sorta to
help build their confidence and with
these period products and the campaign
that we're doing it's important that we
try and get as many girls trying to do
that sort of stuff after school do you
think more should be a more sanitary
products should be available free to
young women these days
I think that's what we're trying to do
here is that laws that are maybe a
little bit less fortunate that can't
potentially afford these products that
are available in schools now they're
available in youth clubs so then
therefore that it allows them not to
have that many excuses of not to take
part and I think for us to have the
availability to have them there allows
them to go right okay well actually
after school a I'm gonna go today I I
feel a lot more comfortable within
myself I can go and do what my friends
are doing and not be able to try and
avoid these sorts of things and what are
the knock-on effects I mean you've
talked about the fact that it gave you
confidence it gave you knowing that
people relied on you gave you more self
belief that carries on into adulthood
doesn't it sort of these girls missing
out on but by not doing these clubs I
think for me I think part of this is for
me not to be able to allow these girls
to miss out on stuff I think I'd hate to
think that maybe that one hour after
school can return should be their career
5-10 years down the line so going along
that instance I think just reflecting
back on my personal experience I think
if I never have had that I don't know
actually know what I would have been
doing today it was kind of when I got my
love for football and for me whether
it's football whether it's hockey net
for tennis whatever it might be it might
be swimming that's not sporty but
allowing girls to be able to have the
opportunity to try and choose something
that they want to do and feel
comfortable doing it yeah great stuff
Stefan love you talk to you thanks very
much for joining us today